well President Biden is spending the
night in Las Vegas after a full day on
the west coast landing at Reed
International the president's motorcade
headed to Summerlin for a private
fundraiser the motorcade forced traffic
closures from the airport connector All
the Way North up to the Summerlin
Parkway sources telling our 8 news now
investigators the fundraiser was held at
the home of the Molasky family in the
tournament Hills Community it raised a
million dollars for the Democratic
National Committee now tomorrow the
president will be holding an event over
at UNLV talking about his plan to lower
prescription costs he will leave on Air
Force One Air Force One a short time
later his departure will cause again
more traffic closures as we take a look
at the map here Metro Police say both
the airport connector and Maryland
Parkway between Tropicana and Russell
will be impacted between 12 15 and 12 45
tomorrow